c'est un soir et y avait j'ai pas vu les
personnes parce que c'était dans le noir
c'était dans le noir non je comprenais
pas j'entendais déjà décrit et je
comprenais pas après c'était à mon tour
on m'avait préparé je ne devais pas
avoir de culottes et j'avais peut-être
un panneau parce que c'est au sénégal
et après ça je crois que j'étais assise
sur les fesses les jambes écartées et je
me rappelle que de ça et dans le noir on
disait pas bougé pas bougé on tenait les
mains et après ça bat les pressages est
excisée
j'ai été excisées et après ça rien il y
avait les soins après autour de moi il y
avait avait des personnes des femmes
c'était dans une pièce noire c'était là
où je vivais avec mes parents mes frères
et soeurs
enfin un om et frères et soeurs et c'est
tout il ya plusieurs formes d'excision
tu sais ça oui voilà il parle de type 1
type de type 3 way ex aequo coupe et les
lèvres les twittos ouais voilà
et qu'est ce que toi tu as été ou est ce
que tu as été coupée toi moi je pense
que enfin de ce qui m'a dit le docteur
c'était ces types de moi c'est un petit
bout du clitoris et des petites lèvres
voilà on m'a rien expliqué jusqu'à
aujourd'hui jusque là aujourd'hui on n'a
pas expliqué en tout cas les personnes
qui doivent m'expliquer m'ont jamais
expliqué pourquoi c'était tabou c'est
quelque chose que que non j'en ai jamais
reparlé réellement même nom quand j'en
passe non jamais jamais parler quand on
dit à un enfant c'est interdit de voler
on va pas lui couper les mains avant
pour pas enfin je sais pas comment
expliquer ça mais on va pas lui couper
les mains ou lui dire d'arrêter de
mentir donc on va lui le coupé la langue
mais là ce serait pour qui à quoi
pour les fins ben les éduquer à rester à
ne pas aller voir ailleurs à rester sage
voilà comme si leur désir était
dangereux voilà et les airs des hommes
bah j'en sais rien je sais pas pour moi
l'excision c'est voilà c'est une coupure
à la vis et on nous coûte tout désir en
fait tout désir à la vie pour moi en
tout cas mon ressenti pour moi c'est ça
c'est à aucun désir même si on essaie il
ya quelque chose qui va pas parce qu'on
a été cassée on est et on a été brisée
quoi quelque part c'est une renaissance
lâche unis pour moi j'ai deux dates de
naissance
gilles 28 mai et j'ai 3 juillet je crois
que j'ai réussi le 3 juillet voilà j'ai
rien à voir
donc
[Musique]
le clitoris c'est quand il a été coupé
il s'est rétracté à l'intérieur du coup
l'opération fait que on le retire et
enfin le on le ressort pour qu'ils
puissent voilà pour qu'on puisse le
ressentir à même à la peau ou voilà quoi
en tant que femme c'est une renaissance
quoi je me sens pour moi je suis plus
excité je suis je suis une femme je suis
une femme à part entière et je suis
contente en tout cas de je suis je suis
très contente de moi je suis fier je
suis voilà je suis fier d'eux je suis
fier de moi quoi j'ai vu les premiers
effets parce que tout de suite c'est un
organe que je connaissais pas mais tout
de suite on a c'est comme wes et une
connexion avec son corps donc c'est une
première connexion c'est quelque chose
comme je sais pas comment le décrire ses
aînés anelik l'électricité qu'on s'est
quand même un petit bout qui est là je
l'avais pas avant mais il a qui est là
et je le touche et je le ressens